hello and welcome back to game review
my name is kill dendi and today I'm
going over Jonathan Francis favorite
chess game of all time or so I'm
claiming and this is something I wanted
to do pretty regularly actually so if
you guys at home have any favorite chess
games of all time leave them in the
comments and there's a pretty good
chance that I'll eventually get to going
over them this is actually a game
between Rubenstein and York Solway maybe
I'm not sure how to pronounce his name
totally and this is a game played all
the way back in 1908 in Lodz so we're
gonna see how this game what it was d4
d5 c4 e6 Knight c3 c5 and this is the
trash defense and this game has actually
kind of become like a model for how to
play against against this system here
Rubinstein played some very convincing
stuff and showed the the serious
deficits that can be that can be made
against the tirage system in the game he
took on d5 black recaptures and now
simply Knight f3 defending d4 you don't
want to capture here right away and
bring this bishop out all the time now
black plays Knight f6
getting developed and now g3 knight c6
and Bishop g2 and the point of whites
play is that this D pawn is a little bit
weak and so white wants to pile up
against this pawn this is why this
Bishop comes to g2 in this line rather
than a natural d3 square black captures
on d4 we see Knight takes d4 we now have
an isolated Queen pawn but after Queen
b6 we see a very common transition from
the i QP to kind of a hanging pawn
structure here where there are pawns on
c6 and d5 like it's castled black plays
Bishop e7 and then White's next move is
actually really important and I wanted
to talk about it a little bit with this
pawn structure pawns on c6 and d5 like
this it's really unclear whether or not
these pawns are going to turn out to be
an advantage or a weakness kind of
goating either way
one thing you don't want to do is really
kind of just like waste some time moves
like this have been played before but if
you waste too much time just getting
slowly develops eventually you're gonna
see this pawn comes out to c5 and once
these pawns have gotten developed
although maybe you can't do it right
away because this pawn might be hanging
we'll say we'll give black a little bit
more time with this move and now we'll
play c5 once these pawns get to c5 and
d5 they control a lot of central squares
and if these pawns can kind of maintain
themselves next to each other like this
it can be a very nice spatial advantage
for black now the opposite of this is if
white can make sure that this pawn on c6
never can advance to c5 they're actually
going to be a little bit of a weakness
oh I can kind of pile up against this
week's e6 pawn in this week's e5 square
and prove to black that these pawns are
definitely a weakness definitely a
detriment to his position and so because
of that white already goes for this move
Knight a 4-1 hitting this Queen and to
keeping an eye on the c5 Square already
this is going to be the theme of the
game white tries to keep c5 under
control and cramp the black position so
black plays Bishop B or Queen b5 rather
white brings this Bishop to e3
like I said controlling the c5 square
black goes ahead and gets castled and
how rook c1 every move for white you see
piles up on this score it's a very
logical way of playing and now a black
makes a little bit of a mistake white
plays Bishop g4 which at first looks
very very natural right you're attacking
this e to pawn and it could be a little
bit awkward to defend it you might have
to play this move f3 and black was
probably thinking well white doesn't
want to play this move f3 because it
stunts his own Bishop but in fact this
was all part of Rubenstein's plan here
by playing f3 he allows this trick to
advance to the f2 square not something
you see every day but in this case it
makes a lot of sense this Bishop is
going to move out of the way and the
rook can actually swing to the Queen
side after this epon advances
and this is all really just giving white
a path to add even more pressure to the
c6 pawn in the game well I came back to
e6 and white now goes ahead and plays
Bishop c5 blockading the c6 pawn making
sure it stays there we see rook e8 and
now why does continue with this move
rook F 297 is black's choice aiming for
the c5 square trying desperately to
regain control of it we see Bishop e7
Rickey 7 and now of course you want to
control c5 why not Queen D for all of
the white pieces work together to
achieve this goal of cramping the black
position rook e8 is blacks choice now we
see Bishop f1 preparing to advance this
pawn this rook now brings itself over to
c8 to help advance the C pawn of course
this a rook is a little bit tied down by
this Queen on d4 as well III is White's
continuation Queen b7 now once again
white blockades this pawn Knight takes
rook takes and really white has forever
sealed the deal with this c5 square so
he's created a permanent weakness in the
black camp now all that's left to do is
maneuver the pieces to the Queen side to
make sure that you can actually break
through and win something concrete and
we'll see how he does that here rook c7
of course the this threat comes over to
c2 as we expected Queen b6 is blacks
choice and now b4 is White's move
already
white is making some very concrete
threats on this Queen side B 5 trends
actually to immediately win this this C
pawn also there's no time to play a move
like Bishop d7 because I move like b5
what would already be winning the game
so instead we see a 6 from black this
move well it does prevent b5 it's not
good enough for black and we see the
very simple rook a5 attacking this a6
pawn and it's very difficult actually
for black to defend
he tries rook b8 countering this threat
with the threat of his own but after a3
this pawn is defended this pawn is
attacked this pawn is attacked a queen
trade is also on the cards and there's
no way to defend everything we see rick
a7 rook takes c6 is a nice little tactic
queen c6 leaves this trick hanging rook
e8 was played Queen Queen back to c5
King b7 simply king up to getting the
king end of the game guarding some of
these weak spots and white is up a clean
pawn this pawn remains weak this Bishop
sucks this bishops great white is going
to win this game
h5 is blacks move simply Bishop b2 g6
Queen d6 in this pawn is hanging Queen
c8 rook c5 keeping the C file rather
than being greedy and taking this pawn
after Queen d7
you see h4 black tries a 5 but now after
rook c7 Queen b8 white makes use of this
extra beep on and starts pushing it out
the board you see the white piece is
very well placed to support these
advances and after a 4 simply b6 and b7
and black went ahead and resign this
game here there's nothing left to do no
matter what black does white is going to
be queening soon and this was a very
model game from Akiba Rubinstein showing
how to play against this pawn structure
how to organize your pieces against a
weakness and then to finally capitalize
win material and go on to win the game
thank you for joining me this week or
this episode on game review as always I
thank you for watching and I'll see you
next time you know try it again
okay so black went ahead and resigned in
this position a model game by a keeper
Rubinstein showing how to play against
this weak pawn structure placing your
pieces around the c5 square and
eventually winning material and
converting thank you so much for joining
me this time on game review
my name is always is Caleb Denby and I
will see you next time